hello everybody and welcome to a
brand-new let's play of tenebrous Lake
now this is probably one of the most
in-depth mods of our custom stories of
amnesia that I've seen it actually had
its own executable file and as you can
see there's a new intro so let's dive
right in
welcome to tenebrous Lake I'm Eva oh
well this is this is the same okay
blah blah blah autosave locations
throughout the mod a cheetah playing a
dark room where headphones for the best
effect I know it's not completely dark
but that's because in the day I gotta
buy giant blank up up on my window
alright good enough
okay now you are ready to play tenebrous
Lake from Boris Game Studios all right
I'm ready
my body is ready Terry oh oh I get to
create a whole new profile whoo
of them that would have been very very
bad
all right cool yeah I've heard that this
has only monsters like totally new
environments new textures in everything
so this should be a good one
I'm a dad okay here go Gardner game ping
pong come on scare me I know you can't
I'm not in there monitor
don't fear the darkness ah that's the
only thing I can think of I can remember
nothing than a damn thing what could
have possibly happened who I am
what I am
or even why I'm here
but even so
the only thing I can think
I'm not afraid of the darkness darkness
is afraid of me all right so Wow well
now that looks familiar
good old amnesia juice make me forget
all my troubles how many people is this
guy murdered
I wonder okay so and still wobbly still
wobbly obviously the character model was
new there wasn't even a single regular
character mom besides I don't know maybe
Anderson what was his name
I totally forgot Alexander it is dark in
here
it's like seriously dark the shadows are
completely back I can't even see into
them ooh boy alrighty now I like the
rain that's something new some up here
anything ooh where's Felix Felix is out
playing on the pitch as always
of course I'm Christine the sound of
course I think so an old family and you
let everybody die oh why am I in this
photo this is my family they seem to be
all dead bro might have to move on in
that regard
ooh baby not supposed to be creepy I bet
but so creepy that ah
beware standing into darkness your
sanity will slowly drain okay whatever
are okay let's see now I can't see a
damn bloody thing I've got I know
nothing I got no nothing okay mmm
ooh is that a note I see a boring Oh
epic jumping miss we got boy a 1300 I
don't need a rear it's been a long
journey but we follow Robert to Memphis
like two neveress long line the place is
smaller than I expected I'm still not
sure why it was so insistent that we
must a little so close this points of
work uh-huh
maybe I just being negative yeah could
be from the from steps is absolutely
gorgeous now from what I thought word
says we can start expanding the house as
soon as he's finished unpacking all the
busts Edwards a demon I can already tell
that Christine seems interested in the
nearby forest and I'm sure Felix will
enjoy going for a swim in the lake on a
hot day mm-hmm truth be told I think I
families could be quite happy in our new
home well you were wrong son you're
wrong cuz they're all dead oh okay
light thinks it travels faster than
anything but it is wrong no matter how
fast it travels it finds the darkness
has always got there first
and is waiting for it save what really
there save point system Oh interesting
hmm looks like they went through them
programming changes in the game as well
okay
alright I'm just waiting for something
to pop out
yeah that was it
I knew something was gonna have huh okay
soku I'm not bothered by goop but I
guess I have to turn around now
hello is anybody home
anybody want to say hi to me you go save
again why not why not why not
hello gee what was the deal with that I
just gonna go back the way I came I
guess so no matter how dark the moment
love and hope are always possible oh
yeah
if you know what I mean okay so that was
waste time jump off into the lake I
could yeah do it
don't be splashing
down all right I am in the lake I'm in
the water now what I forgot a sprint
second that office in Hana he could do
it okay there's like totes dark and I'm
on land hooked up okay maybe it was a
bad idea to come in the water maybe
maybe just maybe I can't see a damn
thing
there's some land over there which was
that
and any second now gonna get to it did I
break the game
I broke the uh I broke the bleedin
bloody game I wasn't supposed to come
here I wasn't supposed to do this you
didn't see anything
you didn't see anything guys you didn't
see anything but now finally here that
adds all a pile of crap okay so I
couldn't go there there's brought
something in the house that I missed I
wouldn't doubt it it's so bloody dark I
can't see what I'm doing go around the
house up and hello Christina I'm
guessing you can freaking see right out
there whoa aah what did I do
oh that's just a piano ah screw you got
my hopes up I thought it was like a
lever or something I can't see anything
man what do they expect me to do and
maybe I had to go like go around the
forest I don't know let me go back
there's nothing over here well obviously
yeah you guys know what's up I get lost
it's no big deal
life's but a walking shadow a poor
player that struts and frets his hour
upon the stage and then is heard no more
yeah yeah I'll save pink Oh saving the
game don't know why it doesn't do an
honest aid
okay so is there any forest I can get
into I can oh oh oh oh it's so gonna get
lost oh no oh no oh not that I need
either of those things but I out I'm
what's in here a way around the guy
who's a way around the I'm such an idiot
I'm the bigger city get there
mommy
okay moving forward hello is anybody
Ruth Turner
do-do-do-do-do
hi oh the whole guy go in the hole
seems like you're good enough plot
device epic dictor oh yeah oh no this
looks like any job I'll put this way
doctor seriously it's like unbelievably
dark
that's stupidly dark okay and it's not
even like when I'm in the darkness it
doesn't do that thing where it changes
and suddenly I can see the dark it just
stays dark okay all right so I need to
find a lantern like wicked bad
nope uh-uh nope no way uh-uh no lock
dude right maybe that was the worst this
way oh there's barely barely changes
there's nothing nothing okay here we go
oh I remember that giant face it popped
up in
oh I'll back outside again
oh that's good I suppose wondering when
I'm gonna see one of those new monsters
okay
life's oh I know I've already read that
one
okay ah that's a little that's a little
brighter a little bit not much done baby
Oh cannot see okay black nothing okay
let's go running out of time for the
first episode let's see come on what do
you got what you got for me bring it on
bring it
oh look back yeah huh
what no nothing nothing
yeah nothing oh la
it's locked it won't budge
it won't budge it's locked all right so
that's that then what do I can't even
see a castle door what do they expect me
to do seriously what do they expect me
to do I can't see jack Oh or not dungeon
darkness cannot drive out the darkness
only light can do that hate cannot drive
out hate only love can do that oh it's a
love story
Oh story but why why go down into the
dungeon Catherine to anyone here oh I
bet I bet I just bet
I just bet I just bet
uber this is the entrance to the dungeon
Wow
you see that big door that door is
preventing anyone from escaping this
place ah damn I see is there no way to
open it no I don't let's go out of the
key for the machine where the lever is
located oh damn
now that's a voice actor that's like the
best voice actor I've heard one of these
who just steam not unless you have oh
okay I don't remember the lines I can't
see anything again can I please please
have a lantern please pretty please you
need to find Lantern what one could be
turned on unless I'm gonna go through
the whole game with no Landreth then I
might have to turn up the gamma a bit
but they gave me
hi okay
and toad duck clearly right a frigate
friend in a funnel later I need to get
the big door open somehow it's a big
door but I could open it all right
I am out of time for the first episode
thank you guys so much thank you guys so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next part
bye Barney